we are playing a long game here and that
change is hard and change is slow and it
never happens all at once but eventually
we get there we always do we get there
because of folks like my dad
folks like Baraka grandmother men and
women who who said to themselves I may
not have a chance to fulfill my dreams
but maybe my children will maybe my
grandchildren will see so many of us
stand here tonight because of their
sacrifice and longing in steadfast love
because time and again they swallowed
their fears and doubts and did what was
hard when you are struggling and you
start thinking about giving up I want
you to remember the power of hope the
belief that something better is always
possible if you're willing to work for
it and fight for it it is our hope that
if we work hard enough and believe in
ourselves then we can be whatever we
dream regardless of the limitations that
others may place on us the hope that
when people see us for who we truly are
maybe just maybe they too will be
inspired to rise to their best possible
selves so don't be afraid you hear me
young people don't be afraid be focused
be determined be hopeful be empowered
empower yourselves with a good education
then get out there and use that
education to build a country worthy of
your boundless promise lead by example
with hope never fear and know that I
will be with you rooting for you and
working to support you for the rest of
my life you just watched two amazing
clips of Michelle Obama take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]